whether these allegations are either
under investigation already or have been
dealt with already in a variety of ways
through the historic abuses system that
has been established through public
inquiries through the UK courts or the
European courts there have been some
cases of abuse that have been
acknowledged and apologies and
compensation have been paid
appropriately but the government has
always been clear and the armed forces
have always been clear that they
absolutely reject allegations of
systemic abuse by the British Armed
Forces the British Armed Forces uphold
high standards they are the finest armed
forces in the world and they uphold
those high standards so we reject
allegations of systemic abuse but where
there are substantiated allegations of
things going wrong these things have
been or are being investigated that does
not require references to the
International Criminal Court so you
would urge the International Criminal
Court when they get these
representations to say we are satisfied
that the UK itself is dealing with it
well that is what they should say yes
and of course the well that they will
now look at anything that is sent to
them but this is being dealt with
properly within the United Kingdom as
I've explained through a very detailed
and exhaustive process as I say we have
ever been caught proceedings public
inquiries a process that is called his
Iraq historic allegations so these
things have been looked at and where
there have been cases they have been
dealt with appropriately but the United
Kingdom armed forces are do not commit
systematic abuse and they as I say
uphold some of the highest standards in
the world